- All right y'all welcome back.
I'm hanging out with
my friend Seth Meyers.
Twitter throws us some
pretty big questions,
all right y'all.
But fear not, Seth and I are
here to give brilliant answers
to those questions in another round of
Kelly's Quaran-Twitter Questionnaire.
(upbeat music)
Here's how it works.
I'll read some of the
most thoughtful questions
we've found on Twitter
during the quarantine,
then Seth and I will help
out with the answers.
Okay, it's like a different
version of Dear Abby.
Here we go.
Our first on today's Twitter questionnaire
comes from @DavidConvucci I think.
"Everyone is talking about
good quarantine habits,
tell me your worst.
I, for one, have started
chewing nicotine gum
for no reason other that it
was on sale at the pharmacy."
What!?
(laughing)
I want your life David,
'cause obviously not a lot is going on
and I'm very busy.
(laughing)
Whats your worst quarantine habit, Seth?
- I don't know I think I'm over flossing
just to, like, break up the day.
(laughing)
- Oh my, you know what I'm doing?
Q tips.
I already am the Q tip queen,
I love cleaning out my ears.
I can't stand, I can't stand
any kind of moisture in my ears
and I've been showering a lot
'cause we live on a ranch,
and I'm probably going
to ruin my ears somehow.
- I, look, I love a good Q
tip, but I like to savor it.
I feel like overusing a Q tip
take a way the excitement.
For me it's a treat.
(laughs)
You know if I accomplish something,
then I'm like, you've
earned yourself a Q tip.
- Yeah, I love cleaning out my ears, okay.
- Can I ask you a Q tip question?
- Yes
- Do you,
do you do one Q tip that
you switch for each ear,
or does each ear get one Q tip.
- Here's the weird thing about me,
it's so interesting you asked.
I do one Q tip, and I do one side,
and then I do the other side deep in,
and then I take another Q
tip and I do the around,
you know in side your,
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then do the same
thing with the other side
- Wow.
- Yeah, it's a process.
- Gotcha.
- I enjoy Q tips, I call
them eargasms, their good.
We might wanna not put that in the show.
Or, I don't know, hell, put it in.
All right the next one
is from @HelloCullen.
"What if Seinfeld met the Sopranos."
(laughing)
That's actually a great question.
- Just like what would happen?
- Yeah, like, so Seth what
do you think, turf war?
Like I'm just saying.
- I don't know.
I think Jerry would be like
what's the deal with Paulie Walnuts?
(laughing)
- Why?
Why is the side of his hair white?
- I think it would be more interesting
to see Cramer with them.
Anyways, I love Seinfeld
- Cramer would definitely
sort of like blow up the mob gang somehow.
- Yes, it would've been a great episode.
Good question.
Okay this next one is
form @JPortnay who asks
"What's the dumbest fight you've
gotten into in quarantine?"
Well, you know what,
(sighs)
here's the thing you should
never ask a married person that
because there's plenty.
- Right, yeah.
- I don't even know, like Brandon and I,
it's just, 'cause it's every,
the kids are crazy, everything's crazy
and we're all together.
I mean you and your wife,
have y'all just,
- Yeah.
- Stupid things.
- Well my,
our two year old, he fell and hit his,
he hit his chin.
And, you know, he split it open,
and I immediately panicked
'cause I thought we were gonna have to
go to the emergency
room, which is obviously
not a place you wanna be right now.
You know because you don't wanna
require the attention of first responders
who are dealing with
more important things.
And basically while I was flipping out
and screaming about how bad it was,
my wife just put a band
aide and said it's good.
(laughing)
Making very clear that I'm
not the person you want
on your crisis team.
- Okay I'm you and my husband is her.
I woulda been like oh my god!
I can't even, there's not even,
we've had so many dumb
arguments, like stupid.
And then we, and then
literally in the moment
we're like this is so stupid.
Like let's just go have a drink.
The next one though was
posted by @laurawags.
"I turn 27 this weekend.
What are people doing
for birthdays besides Zoom calls?"
Well I spent mine alone
because I know a lot of
people are in isolation
and they don't have people
living in their house,
but I have many people living in my house
and I wanted to be alone on my birthday
and it was beautiful.
What about you?
- Yeah, I mean guess like those VR goggles
where I would just sit
and be somewhere else.
- Oculus!
- Oculus, yeah.
- I have those, they're so cool.
My daughter loves to do the deep sea one.
It's so cool.
But then she freaks out.
No, that's good one, that's a good idea.
Unless you don't have, you know,
a VR thing and then it just
looks like we were bragging.
- Do you know what also works
is two toilet paper rolls,
and you just hold your phone against it.
- Yeah, and it just
seems like you're there.
All right last question in the
Quaren-Twitter Questionnaire,
I hate saying that, comes from
@rtomashoff34, what a handle.
"If you could be quarantined
with a superhero,
who would you pick and why?
Also, who would be the worst
superhero to be stuck with
in a house?"
(laughs)
- Oh my gosh, well I feel like Wolverine,
you don't want to be stuck with someone
who has, you know, claws.
Just, you know, it would get angry fast,
so I would say you don't want a Wolverine.
I mean, you know all things being equal
I feel like Batman's pretty resourceful.
You know, has the most stuff on his belt.
- And rich, he has all that cool stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, so I think that
would be my choice, yeah.
- Honestly I was gonna
pick Batman as well,
but then I thought flying would be fun.
It would really be a way
to get out of the house,
so maybe I might go
with Superman.
- Yeah, but then
I think a lot of people would be like,
you gotta fly with a mask on
because you have particles.
(laughs)
And I feel like if the first time I fly,
I don't wanna ruin it with that.
- I think what's funny, the
best part of your answer
with Wolverine is every female
just disagreed with you.
- Yeah, that's fine.
- Every female is like mm,
I'd rather have Wolverine
in my room with me separate.
That was a good one.
All right well, hey
thank you so much, Seth.
It's always good to see you.
I know that you're slammed with work,
we all are right now and
we're trying to, you know,
keep everyone distracted
and, you know, 'cause it's
kind of a scary uncertain time.
But everybody, y'all can watch
"Late Night with Seth Meyers"
weeknights on NBC.
It's seriously one of
my favorite shows ever.
He's so great y'all should watch it.
We will be right back.
(upbeat music)